holy [ __ ] we got stuff to talk about it
right so the new Iron Man three trailers
hit the Internet the term new implies
that there was a first there was another
one and there's not the first the first
Iron Man 3 trailer has hit the Internet
so let's talk about that [ __ ] this is
what I like about this trailers quite a
few things actually first of all it
shows that the events of the Avengers
has left its mark on Tony Stark
nothing's been the same since New York
experienced things and then they're over
I can't sleep and I imagine they would
it was a whole it was a big deal the
dude stopped an alien invasion that will
stick with you then they go on to show a
lot more and I'm telling you this movie
you feel like Tony Stark is going to
lose a lot if not everything starting
with Pepper Potts just a hundred people
who want to kill me I hope I can protect
the one thing I can't live without
yeah early on in the movie don't tell
the chick that she's like the most
valuable thing to you because that's
just like this movie code right there
it's kind of like saying I'll be right
back in a scary movie you won't be back
and when you say you're the one thing I
can't live without that means she won't
be back but this is when the trailer
gets epic it's just it's right here
children
right there when they were blown up the
mark seven six five I was like ah no
just funny because Studios like now iron
Patriot's not in this movie he's in the
look guys he's not in this movie he's
not he's not yeah he is America some
people call me a terrorist I consider
myself a teacher
but I love that the movie is doing this
it shows Tony star mean everything
disgust wiped out you know when you're
playing a game against a friend and you
have that move that thing you can do
that just wipes the board clean it looks
like that is what happens to Tony Stark
he gets his board wiped clean
Tony Stark's entire world looks like
it's coming to a crumbling halt and I
love that and I'll tell you why Tony
Stark won't have his toys to rely on
anymore apparently he has like one Iron
Man suit that he's hauling through the
snow at the end of the trailer but
ultimately if they do this right we'll
have the same feeling an Iron Man 3 that
we had at the beginning of one he was in
the cave which is he has nothing in the
world except his intellect that is his
best weapon in situations like this and
to me it's the most interesting part of
the whole thing the coolest part of Iron
Man 1 was when he was in the cave I
loved seeing that so if we get a lot
more of that in Iron Man 3 I am down
with this this trailer is completely
epic as a teaser trailer I never expect
anything from teaser trailers except
tone but with this trailer I watched it
a few times over you can't help it just
watching Tony Stark's world get
destroyed like that you're like yeah
that's what happens when you come out
and say I am Iron Man
you think the dude from wrestler with a
couple of electric whips was bad news
try Ben Kingsley in a budget of
helicopters in rakesh your world is done
so Iron Man 3 looks great I was
skeptical but I heard Jon Favreau wasn't
gonna direct it but what can I say the
trailer has now won me over they could
have put all the best stuff in this
trailer and the movie could be a piece
of [ __ ] I don't think it's gonna be a
piece of [ __ ] it looks kick-ass so what
did you think about the Iron Man 3
trailer comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you